welcome back everybody to the internet's
favorite show can we say that
konichiwa yeah we're greeting our
japanese viewers as well
shalom to our hebrew viewers and
wow we are worldwide people we are
we are global we don't discriminate and
you know what today we're episode
we're episoded by our sponsor sponsored
by
adam and eve adam and eve use code h3 we
love adam we love them
love love love love love okay so trisha
showed me that adam and eve and i'm not
endorsing this product this is amazing
maybe we should wait for the ad read to
show it
stick around for that ad read okay
right it's just it's just it's a time
it's a keychain body massager it's a
it's a little vibrator on a keychain
it's like that sounds disgusting you
don't want to carry that around on your
keychain then
you know put it where the sun don't
shine well
it's four okay the surface yeah yeah but
still i don't want it there either
well you don't have one so it doesn't
matter that's like rubbing like the edge
of my [ __ ] with like
on the key equivalent i feel like we
have to cut this because it's the
beginning right we can't talk about it
well they'll tell us we need to
it's like the what is that called let's
talk about on the ad you're right you're
right
what's the soft part of the balls what's
in between the goose the balls and the
is that what it is the balls
that's the the most disgusting part
though what does that call it
the grouch no
no it's the it's the skin between the
balls and that's so i know what you're
talking about
the grendel the grouch there's another
name the taint
that's it you know why they call it the
taint because it's tainted
it's disgusting okay
this episode is off to the wrong side i
hate everybody this week i'm celebrating
let's
go we love that the best episodes but
i'm angry too
i'm angry are you angry at logan paul i
made a whole episode
fight i'm going to show you the clip he
made a comment that got me so fired up i
dedicated and whole an entire episode to
him
were you really fired up or you're like
oh this good clip babe you actually got
fired up or no did you think about it
after
wait really i don't real i mean i don't
really get fired up i don't get like
angry but i was like
[ __ ] this guy get anxiety over it no i
don't yeah it doesn't really get to me i
was just like this guy's such a [ __ ]
ass
why do you let it bother you because
it's logan like nobody takes it he
called me
well because he i'll show you you'll see
what i mean okay i'll show you that but
first so we are sponsored by emily thank
you so much
oh i have a fun announcement everybody
you think we haven't been seeing it i've
been seeing everybody begging
for the frenemies merch teddy fresh yeah
here look we're it's done we're doing it
oh my god we are working with teddy
fresh's finest
to bring you frenemy's merch this is
just the mock-ups but but
so we're going to go into production it
should take a few months so
starting off with the split zip up
hoodie i love that
so much these are appliques so it's
going to be a zip up
it's going to be a cut and sew and
applique
fired by our set yeah yeah yeah of
course
and then so this was my favorite teddy
fresh design ethan gave me his
sweatshirt of
teddy fresh it was beige and black like
this and i wear all the time it's my
favorite sweater
yeah it's weird amazing so we made that
into the front of it it's basically
oh my god and then we're doing we're
we're not sure if we should make a
little short sleeve alongside we're
going to sample both and see
but it's going to be a cut and so shirt
i love both yeah we can just do both
you guys have the best quality socks
that's what you want so excited
i was so excited you guys showed this
because i like mentioned it casually
because i love skater socks and then i
saw it i was like
um those are just for you because i'm
not i'm not wearing those oh my
god beanie so that's so it's just
it's just a little oh i'm excited
it's just a little capsule and if it
does well i'm sorry shredder if people
like it we can do like another
drop but it's gonna be really fun i'm
just gonna do like teddy fresh.com
for enemies and we'll just and we'll
have like our own we'll make like a fun
little page
it's gonna be awesome i am so excited
about this i will wear it all the time
like i am like so
proud this hoodie is gonna be really
nice really really i love it
so that's fun that's exciting
everybody's been wanting this so
here it is it's coming give us a few
months if this show lasts for a few
it's gonna be crazy if like we get in a
huge fight and then
we have all this clothes but it'd be
like limited edition you know what i
mean like people would be like oh
remember that time when front of me is
like was a thing
it's true i think a collector's item
people will still buy it like rest in
peace for enemies
the rest of the piece for enemies
dropped when the show ends that's what
you do i promise you
i promise you that no matter what
happens i'll still give you your cut
i get a cut of it of course you never
told me that
what what do you think i'm just making a
bunch of money off frenemies of course
i'm giving you a cut
oh oh my god that's so nice
i'm i i feel bad that you even thought
that we were gonna pocket all the money
i felt bad that like
i've like i don't know i felt like oh my
god i can't believe like they're doing
something that involves me like with
their brand like i felt so honored
like i thought it was an honor i didn't
think it was gonna get money for it
that's how jeffrey got you when he used
your name of course we're gonna give you
money
work work this is our project oh my god
oh i'm so excited i should set up like a
photo shoot maybe i'll do like a music
video for it i'm so excited now this is
so cool of course we're giving
giving you a call because it's like your
people and your resources and
even this was like your design like oh
my god of course
oh my god should we do a photo shoot
okay how about you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we run rock of love when they
each did like a photo shoot for brett
michaels we should like each produce our
own photo shoot for each other
for frenemies like you would do it how
you would do your photo shoot it sounds
like a lot of work no but then i can
make those like emo rock stars i guess
we can
we can turn it into an episode turn it
into content maybe i'll give you like an
emo wig half black half pink
like you know what i mean like lookie
like that'd be so fun okay and it would
be like on trash cans and with like
paint splatter like pink and black paint
like holy [ __ ] to promote it
i can't believe you didn't think that i
was going to give you a cut that's
shocking to me
that's talking to me that you would
you're so not to i'm fine with that
this is our thing yeah but you're very
like i started this i
put up all the money for the thing it's
in my house my people
my resources i like that but not a bad
way i get it
wait how am i like that i split i always
i split everything with you
um yeah true
including the merch would you thought i
was just gonna pocket at all i'm done
i'm not gonna oh my god
you know what your cut is out it's all
i'm keeping it up i would have gotten
pink
maybe i'll get pink and black nails for
our front of me i'm very excited about
this wow
holy [ __ ] that's great yeah no it's
going to be awesome we're going to be
baller we're going to get the house in
maui sooner than we thought
yeah you guys that's right girl
we actually don't make that much in
front of me because we have to split it
just fyi for people i don't know people
think i'm like baller from front of me
i'm not that baller wow we do good on
friends i mean
we make more that's not our main income
i mean it's fun i love it but
we're killing it over here okay are you
playing it down
you do good you are balling no but we're
not making like hundreds of thousands of
dollars a month like you know
no if we had more sponsors we would but
they're starting to come in thank you
adam and eve
thank you hey no dude i don't want to
say i but
i sent you a pretty fat check last month
yeah well i thought it'd be fatter
actually because it's wiper
are you kidding me you thought it would
be fatter
when i was calculating and this is just
adsense it's just youtube adsense
i had to do a double take i was like no
that can't be right you thought it'd be
fatter
yeah oh can i say how much it is no no
no we are not tacky
well i'm wearing teddy brush so don't
even come for me
no i'm not coming for you but i can't
believe you're complete i was
shocked i was like holy [ __ ] how much
did you expect to get you
you were just doing a podcast you come
here once a week i mean jesus
that gave a lot of like emotion i got
triggered a bunch i thought oh well
maybe i'll get a bigger paycheck but it
didn't work
oh back to having good mental health
this month what what are you talking
about you're saying you tried to shame
me into paying you more
no i'm saying i like think i trick and
let myself be triggered more for the
paycheck you know for the scandal
for the controversy moses you know how
much she got paid right yes
that's amazing isn't it okay don't
what oh my god now i have to say her
yeah you thought her channel alone it
was like triple that
well good for her no but what i'm saying
i have you to think too because i
remember i did all those h3 videos like
they [ __ ] suck
which i was actually pissed at you like
i really was pissed at you guys i should
take them down now it doesn't matter
that's over
whatever nobody cares yeah yeah thanks
to me by the way you just made a bunch
of videos [ __ ] on me on your channel
and got like a billion views
isn't that crazy how drama works like
that like uh when he does i just want to
get into drama
we need to have fake dramas i don't like
it with you guys though because you guys
are like you know
we're family now yeah we are it's pretty
crazy but that's why it's so good
i feel so boozy i'll tell people so they
love everyone love this jacket my nail
artist my hair and everyone like it i
was like
yeah my future sister-in-law designed it
she's like how did they get the care
bears they were so like impressed like
people who don't know which is
impressive anyway by the way you see the
little custom buttons too yeah
like the the custom those are because we
love the tag that came with it the tag
was like so good quality i shook up the
t i have the tag at home like the little
bear that comes with it it was so
bouche dude we we're dude teddy fresh is
on another level this year no you guys
are and like i have this
i don't want to say i don't want to get
behind the sauce in the sausage
factory too much but like we we have 25
employees and some of our employees are
like who have been with us a while or
like
top dog people yeah like our
i don't want to say i don't say anything
i don't want to get in the sausage
factory that's why i feel so like
honored to have friend of me merge with
your people
like i kind of felt like that was my
goal from the beginning like oh maybe i
can have like some connects or something
and now i have to connect now i have
like a merch
this is gonna be so fun can i can i show
the care bears thing i wanted to show it
off a little bit
do you have percentage in front of me
now i'm so excited
you don't get a percentage of this just
to be clear
no you don't get the care bearing i'm
the model can i get a model fee
so we got the color block so oh wait
hold on a second yeah can i be on a
billboard
you put oliver tree on a billboard yeah
why don't you ever ask me to be on a
billboard
he was like send me a bunch of teddy
fresh i'm gonna model it and take
awesome photos do you have a better
model than this i have the matching hair
i have the i'm like
that was his thing he wanted to do that
so did he pay for the billboard
[ __ ] i would pay for it um
no you would pay for it yeah okay done
no it wasn't real i didn't i didn't want
to break the thing because
oliver really wanted it to be why didn't
he pay for it he's got money
oliver's just wanted it to seem like it
was real i feel bad and betraying all
over now but
i can't i i can't like i cannot tell a
lie
like abraham was it uh george washington
cannot right yeah
he i cannot tell i was his thing i can
well yeah but that's not that
interesting but i like what you i can
tell a lot
you defended me though and you said i
don't lie i do exaggerate because i
don't like to say like oh
ethan raped me you know what i mean no
trick or warning maybe i shouldn't say
that sleep but i don't know but i don't
just lie like they're maybe
there's always i no i agree i i've never
known you to i don't think you're a liar
make stuff up about people you
exaggerate you distort but you don't
work or maybe i'm like just see it a
different way like maybe my perception
of how our thing went is different
but i'm never just like oh my god you
don't make [ __ ] up yeah you don't make
[ __ ] up
i agree thank you for defending me
there's a difference between being
dramatic and being a pathological liar
you're not a pathological no because i
don't just make [ __ ] up because people
can't do it even if
i've known pathological pathological
lies they're like i went
they just make [ __ ] up yeah it didn't
happen
and if i like lie about people like like
influencers i've talked about like they
can verify if i'm lying or not so when i
say like dave and jacob showed up when i
went to the mental hospital that's true
they were there there's like there's
there's validation
behind it you know what i mean dude your
hair is off the chain today thanks
it matches the jacket it's like damn it
it was crazy yeah i
i just had his wig yeah it's it's that's
tyler fresh's fridge
that's what i'm saying i should get like
a modeling fee or something oh
stop that's a fine i get the frenemies
merch cut yeah this is exciting
okay so anyway let me just show this off
real fast because i'm so proud of it
now this sold out so fast that like this
this was really crazy
um this is the color block hoodie this
is like the classic where we always have
like
the care bear with the with the teddy
fresh bear so
we drew the teddy fresh bear as a care
bear
and had them team up i love it and um
by the way if you i just recommend
following teddy fresh on instagram
because
we are going to restock a lot of this
stuff that's sold out for updates this
is the jacket trish is wearing you could
see it but
i love the jacket what size does it go
up to probably
three well it's a female jacket so it
only goes up to xl
triggered well with the sizes are
different when you do just
female versus unisex yeah and
so the shorts uh pins belt hat these
ones sold out super fast
yeah this is the print all over we did a
nighttime color
you know and the photos turned out
really good too i'm happy
and then the daytime color cute yeah
it turned out really good super stoked
also oh can we definitely
i mean i'm just going to show you it's
great so the cardigan
i got that too i haven't worn it yet
love it though this one sold out i mean
this cardigan is so nice it's like
it's made out of uh what is it called
this it's a special kind of wool
uh angora wool
yeah it turned out really good and um
i think that's pretty much i mean you
know there's a whole bunch of stuff here
you just go to teddyfresh.com
and check it out follow us on instagram
thank you what
that's great were you gonna say
something um
we also got lady gaga chromatical okay
yeah so once again
did you tell did you tell telepathically
put this out in the world
i didn't telepathically i just straight
up asked people to get me these and
someone did send me these overnight but
they were supposed to come today so i
haven't gotten these yet
who did you ask them tick tock you've
put out a tick-tock
to the world triple i said if someone
can buy these i'll like paypal you
triple of what
shipping and all that will be and so
someone got these cookies and the mcr
airpods and
they were like 25 but the shipping
overnight was gonna be 80
so i paid them 150 but we
got it for you for free because we can
do everything here at the hd podcast i
was actually
impressed this is we got not just one
but two of them
yeah can i keep one for me keep one
unopened mint condition
stockx stockx of course let's open it up
oh my gosh i find it so silly that
there's a craze over oreos oh it's lady
gaga chromatica
why is the leggy lady gaga teaming up
with orioles why don't you do a
if she's collaborating fresh it would be
killer yeah but oreo she's a [ __ ]
cookie
that's true she doesn't look like she
eats oreos no no offense i wish i could
be skinny and resist the oreos but
you're opening that bag with like
the delicacy of a new mother
my god just rip it open i love it so
much okay
whoa this is an interesting color
palette kind of watermelon
yeah why is it i thought they'd be more
pink it's like green and
water watermelon what is that color
that looks disgusting it's green feeling
no i'm out whoa i don't like them
i'm kind of stale tell me you don't like
that it's not good
i love oreos and it tastes stale
lady gaga drop the ball
i mean i like the packaging wow what's
the worst oreo i've ever had
i know that you are committed to loving
this no i don't love lady gaga i don't
like live for her
but you were definitely no i know i kind
of ruined my
talk to be like this is amazing i'm
gonna brush that out
um i'd definitely be still that's weird
okay so i actually should say what we're
doing today so
we have a are you going somewhere
no i'm sorry i was like peace
you done we're doing a bake-off
so the objective here is that we are
going to try to recreate
an image of a an intricate cake
ourselves i don't know if that's it but
i'm going to do a a yorkie
because i love my doggie and you are
doing
a barking one of yeah one of those bags
you love
yeah i do love a bergen and the winner
and the
the loser has to donate a thousand
dollars to the other person's charity
yeah i was playing oh we announced it i
think we talk about it
okay spoiler we already shot it who
cares
break the yeah we shot it first our
hands are staying but yeah
we're sick from the cake that's why i
was surprised i hate the oreo because i
just had a bite because i had to taste
it but my god that's a bad oreo
and what else well also everything else
we're going to talk about is
logan paul triggered me and sent me into
a rage and i punched a hole in the wall
oh i feel you're being so dramatic i'm
kidding i didn't put you on that's
because when there's an actual issue no
one's gonna take you seriously because
you're like oh the logan paul thing like
everything you do is like a joke
well like now look like yeah i mean
because i'm not i don't really get angry
but i do think [ __ ] logan paul
you'll see and then also i have a bunch
of david dobrik and
jason nash stuff just based on this
comment that had a lot of points i said
i'm not gonna lie i would love to i
would love for tristan ethan to sit down
and watch the clips from david's vlogs
and
that her trish ethan stop having a
stroke
and try again the sugar
i'm not gonna lie i would love for
tristan ethan to sit down and watch the
clips from david's vlogs that hurt
trisha i feel like it would give ethan a
better
look into why tricia is so hurt by david
and jason
i think a lot of her past traumas come
from what happened between her
and jason is that true i think my trust
with like influencers in general like
like i really thought they were my
friends so when you kept being like i'm
here for you i'm your friend and i was
like um you know what i mean i feel like
maybe a lot of that is
i think there's plenty of other things
that cause trauma in your life before
that though
i think that they really i went to a
mental hospital for the first time in my
life after
david and jason like they showed up to
the hospital to see her sinai before
going to mental hospital
and then they admitted to me at mental
hospital as soon as they came i tried to
run off the stretcher
david and jason were both back there in
the hallways to your side and i am like
why are you both [ __ ] back here david
wait wait wait
what he wasn't filming was he they were
out filming but they weren't filming in
the thing
so they were out filming jeff widdick
came and i was like what the [ __ ] like i
i like whatever my makeup artist took me
to the hospital you didn't want to see
them or what
no i did not want to see them jason was
like okay i guess to be back there
because we were like kind of dating at
the time
but as soon as david got back there i
took out all my clothes and made a run
for it outside the hospital and they
took me and they gave me um they sedated
me and then they told me i had to go to
a mental hospital when you saw david you
just were like
i freaked the [ __ ] out because i was
already in a panic like in a state of
panic
and um like when i woke up because i
like kind of like overdosed and then i
woke up i came to and cedar sinai
and i like he was back then i was so
embarrassed and then i saw david and i
was so [ __ ] livid because that's why
i mean the whole thing started from
david whatever the [ __ ] and
um i saw him and i like [ __ ] freaked
out and i ran so i tried to
go on a thing they strapped me down for
the rest of the night i'm like crying
jason's sitting there i'm like sobbing
because they're like strapping me down
like i'm [ __ ]
hannibal hannibal and um or a cannibal
and i could they're gonna give me a
tampon anyways it was dramatic it was so
traumatic
anyways long story short me and david
like were like i saw him every single
day for like two years of our lives or
whatever went to thanksgiving at his
house all this crazy [ __ ]
that night at the hospital i went to
mental hospital he made jason cut me off
and i never heard from him again he
never was like are you okay after i got
out of the hospital
nothing just cut me off said no one can
talk to tricia no one's allowed to talk
about her he talked about me in a stream
one time a live stream
and that's the only stream he never like
re-uploaded he made sure that was like
disappear off the internet because
someone brought me up
so like if you talk like no one's
allowed to talk about me how do you know
he's told jason don't
jason ever contacted you after that yeah
he like blocked me well no we did talk
we talked secretly for like
three months and what makes you think
that it was um
david because he told me because we
talked secretly for three months like we
hooked up and jason said
i have to dump you like i don't have a
choice
really have you said that publicly
yeah that's psycho yeah it's crazy it's
because
people will not believe you because
that's like so well called their friend
a really good friend of theirs and their
vlog out like he was he was dating a
minor
and he was in the vlogs and david asked
about their sex life in the vlogs when
she was 17 and like i called that out
and i think that was like the big issue
because oh he didn't want to rock the
bow
lee i'm sure but whatever okay well we
don't regret it
i mean don't date miners how about that
it's pretty easy if you're 24.
it's so easy it's like so easy so easy
just don't
they little i mean really it is so easy
it's very simple
so anyway let's go through first of all
we get first pedophiles by putting them
in the thing dom too dom did sexual
assault to girls at vidcon i don't know
what these people are i'm not familiar
with the
blog but he he goes through people in
the
vlog squad like he he just he grabs
people and discards them like you know
flavor of the week like i remember big
nick do you remember big nick like he
was in every vlog and then
he like he just i don't know what
happened or i don't know why he left
but it's like he just used these people
and disposed them like of
like uh well his one minority friend in
the vlog seth did this whole expose on
him last year during the summer of like
how basically he like did watermelon
jokes and like made him do all these
things oh my god
dude i some of the [ __ ] i saw was crazy
how he made out with
jason without knowing yeah and then he
was oh my god so we're gonna watch all
that because
this is all new to me then when seth
made the video and i wasn't that close
to that's not like i'm like whatever but
one sent me the videos like people were
coming for him
calling him like a clout chaser and
stuff and i was like i feel bad
you can tell that he was really upset
yeah
it's crazy people do stuff for like
whatever money or whatever but
i i start to see your point the more i
look into it that david
has like immunity from criticism
from everything even even the vlog spot
no one cares anymore because they're
like irrelevant without david but like
they all went on a trip this weekend to
like the mountains and they're like all
together like 20 them with no mask like
you guys are [ __ ] idiots
meanwhile james and charlie and all
these people are getting dragged like
majorly
i guess because they're just not
relevant anymore no one cares about 30
year old vloggers
people care about david a lot but not
the rest of them name one other vlog
squad member
jason jason big nick but he's
he was canceled there's like a core
group of people that are in the squad
still and he like you know anyways it
doesn't matter i just keep up with them
because they're actual i just
there are certain people and people like
why do you enjoy the demise of some
people because some people are actually
awful human beings like these people not
wearing their masks right now like i
can't wait for their demise because
they're
actually problematic people they're
actually like killing people like
oh shout out to um d'angelo wallace knew
uh
he made a whole oh god you're friends
with him now you're auntie shane pro
d'angelo
shane doesn't mean i'm pro d'angelo well
anyway
he made a really good video about all
these influencers
who are spreading kovid and it was a
really great video and i liked it a lot
he he did it he went there anyway
i don't trigger you why you don't have
to defend shane anymore i'm not
defending him but doesn't mean i'm pro
d'angelo why don't you like d'angelo
um because i don't like the video he
made about us in front of me saying that
you were exploiting my
my mental illness while he's doing the
same thing and making his
thumbnails he was on our podcast you
know i didn't see it we prayed we
we he was all good we buried the house i
wasn't on it don't bury it for me
okay all right for the record so let me
show you this clip first before we get
into all the david's stuff it is
impressive he has
not doesn't sound shady but i don't mean
a shady like that you can do that much
research and put together such
a piece like i didn't watch the full
thing on shane yet but the expose
i was just like how long did this take
you
no i mean as far as commentary channels
go he's got to be one of the best like i
when i was watching his
content he's so thorough and and
um his delivery's good he's funny i like
the guy what can i say i'm a fan
i called out um this commentary channel
that has like literally 2000 views every
video or whatever
there's a lot of drama channels i have
like 2000 views a video there's nothing
whatever so i said one that shane is
clearly feeding this person information
i know it because shane feeds the
information he's feeding this person's
information to be like
she did this remember this like trying
to bring up stuff from my past and like
this person's like rehashing it whatever
anyways like four different of these
like little drama channels all thought i
was talking about them and they're just
all like oh trish was clearly talking
about us getting
information from shane which makes me
believe he is doing that
and i know because they're shane stands
and i was like oh my god they called
they called themselves out i was like i
only knew one
and then i saw these other ones that
claimed that i was talking about them
too and i was like
and then i saw their little shitty
videos i get a thousand views and trying
to bring up old [ __ ] and i'm like
this is shane being like remember when
trisha did this like she did this like
there was stuff where they
uh it's crazy everybody's gonna take
that one guy um don't
why don't do that why i gotta take it
one title obviously whatever joyce
sparkle bs i'm
gonna take down her video i'm trying to
get her channel she did 30 videos about
me and the title tricia paid us raped
moses
oh well like you can't just first of all
not true and you can't just
say that it's cool so okay
moses dated minor is not true like you
can't [ __ ] just
make [ __ ] up so you can you can sue her
for defamation but you can't she has no
money that's the problem these people
are
are broke pissed as [ __ ] and all that
stuff like that and it's like they get
away with it because they have nothing
to lose they have no reputation and you
guys are gross they're just gross
i just want the channel taken down but
that's not but that's not how the dmca
works that's for copyright
okay but if you open a lawsuit youtube
will be more on an app to take down the
videos if you're saying i raped somebody
then you then then they're doing
defamation and you sue them that's how
the law works
i just want you to i'll do it just to
get the youtube channel on because she
has no money i won't win the money if
they can at least get the channel down
because they can't
you can't yeah if you if you win a
lawsuit then then
then the you can that's not like
fair use or anything like that's not
fair use you're literally saying that
that's like a sear that's a crime that
you're saying it's like yeah and that's
why my mother that's why defamation
exists
yeah that's a big one so and that was
crazy and i was like this girl's there's
something wrong with her but surely
there's not that much views on it
like a thousand two thousand i mean i
wouldn't i wouldn't but she did like
30 videos and like it won't stop and i
was like okay but this is shane and i
know because he feeds people information
i'm talking
about whatever
you know what and it's like i it's just
no it's just more the principle of it
like i'm just not going to let
them sorry they're like the worst kind
of backwoods
dude there's so many little channels
like that that are willing to say and do
anything like
if you get too concerned with each one
it's just no but sometimes you got it
just for the principles of it like you
can't
literally say true okay but i don't
murdered herpes
i just don't want you to get yourself in
trouble so don't do a dmca because that
is illegal
i'm not i never said i was gonna do well
you said you want to get the channel
taken down so i thought that's what you
meant
because it's like it's clear straight up
harassment
there's no mechanism through youtube
where you can get it removed for that
reason yeah there totally is bullying
and harassment i've been filing it all
around
okay bowling making so many videos about
the same person okay
yeah they do look leafy leafy's here got
his channel taken yeah okay okay if
that's what you meant then i agree you
can get it down for me a thousand
percent it's just
it's just a lot like okay one or two
fine you're gonna but you're gonna keep
perpetuating these like lives
so here let me show you i love it so i
hope you guys enjoyed it you're a little
pissed
they're gonna make 10 videos out of this
hi just wave hi
oh my god hi [ __ ] oh god i mean i
feel bad for these people but whatever
so let me show you what logan said and
you tell me if i'm overreacting
if i i mean i talked about for like an
hour am i overreacting
no this is the video logan said about
except my situation that just happened
on my overreacting
well it's an opportunity listen i
wouldn't say you're not
i wouldn't say you're overreacting
because it's hard not to feel offended
when someone's making such outrageous
and defamatory statements about you
in public but because it's such a small
amount
of of views that like at a certain point
it's probably healthier for you to just
forget it try to forget it exist
then then try to commit a wage of war on
them
because there's such a small target that
like ultimately
it's a lose-lose for you any attention
you give them
benefits them and any attention you give
them
not only doesn't benefit you it just
wastes your precious time and energy
which they're just so far beneath you
not that
okay thank you for that you're welcome
i'm over it you can keep the channel up
hi enjoy [ __ ] maybe you get a couple
views out of this
it's crazy it's insane people are nuts
there's so many bad things that i do
that you can
make a video about me for like at least
stick to some of the truth well i'll
tell you one of these channels made a
video when
when we've when you were coming on our
normal show before we had frenemies
and she goes this pissed me off because
it's like
they just straight up [ __ ] lie she
goes h3h3
and trisha are faking drama for viewers
and i was like
you really think this shit's fake and
then the whole thesis was like wow h3
has fallen
so far now he's faking views
for clout and i was like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about i mean i guess it
worked you're back up to like booming on
this channel not that you were ever down
but you have your peaks
i'm not faking anything that's what i
took umbrage well i don't know like
what your day portray beef probably
wasn't that serious
yeah but i was pretty up front like hey
i'm just starting stupid beef with dave
pork boy
they said i was faking drama with you
can you just say that's not true oh yes
okay thank you but i think you like
exaggerate drama with people
yes i know i'm very upfront with that
it's just for fun i say i literally said
in the beginning of this podcast with
logan paul i said i'm the king of petty
beef
all i need is a crumb and you gave me
the whole [ __ ] loaf
like yeah it's just fun for me wow i
wonder who influenced me to be like that
treasure why are you looking i'm not
see this one's [ __ ] everyone goes
wow trees are really rubbed up on ethan
why you looking so outraged at me
can you just watch this clip oh my god
the whole can i just show you a clip
all my drama is real i don't have penny
drama
so what are you talking about my drama
is real too okay let's hear it see it
just can i have a moment please jesus
okay here we go i like impulsive i watch
impulsive okay fine
i like it for the record i have somebody
turn off your power
you know while you're trying to
microwave uh okay so roman
antwood was being harassed by a hacker
oh yeah i saw that story
okay so here's what he's here so here's
what they say about here's what logan
paul says about
antwood being harassed postinos the
little pizza rolls
the access to his power grid that
terrifies me because he has children
children that's like what what are the
cameras facing
do you get what i'm saying like yeah i
hear creepy stories about that stuff all
the time
they get like why couldn't they get like
a scum of the internet
[ __ ] like keemstar h3
honestly daniel keem he's one of the
biggest most well-respected boxers
the low low well at least they went for
guys they didn't go for me that was good
that was nice they didn't he said ladies
out of it
he says why couldn't they go for scum of
the internet like
h3 who by the way also has a kid they go
oh he has a kid how could they do that
he goes
yeah go for h3 and ruin his [ __ ] life
and i thought it was pretty ironic
that he has the balls to call me scum of
the internet
when logan paul is out there filming
dead [ __ ] bodies so i was like okay
logan let's see who's scum of the
internet
and i basically dedicated an entire hour
and a half segment to
showing all the crap he's done in his
career and i said [ __ ] you you're scum
on the internet
i rest my case and i rest in my case
right wow you really are not you're not
nothing i mean it's logan paul it's not
like it was you know joe rogan's anger
that's coming with the internet you know
what i mean like
that's like when i call people scum of
the internet like it's just like i call
everybody that like
dude he was serious he was like why
can't i think he wants anyone to come
actually harass you
come on let me have my phone okay
i mean it's not bad i said foot soldiers
prepare for war the whole thing was
tongue-in-cheek okay so you don't really
care
but you want to know what we did no i'm
not like losing sleep over it
but logan paul had a really good wiki
feat rating
he was at like 4.6 on wiki feet and uh
the foot soldier is my that's what i
call my gang you know
some people have like the low gang
that's his gang i'm the foot soldiers
can you see the stan
he's at a 1.25 shame i don't think he
promotes it like you do
but he had a really good rate really
yeah he was like 4.5 or something
4.6 dude [ __ ] you do not cross the foot
soldiers
this is what happens when i get in beef
oh hahaha people think funding over the
internet's fun
no there's consequences to that one
point two five out of five
rest my [ __ ] case slogan just came to
my defense at the hair by j situation
too they got him to go private on
instagram yeah the foot soldiers don't
[ __ ] around
do you ever wonder what they look like
in real life like people that call
themselves
they're jacked handsome rich best job
i'm not trying to go to their luck
they're just wondering what those kind
of people
are what do they do they're engineers
entrepreneurs astronauts
phds for sure i wonder if the foot
soldiers are also in the low gain do you
have any crossover
oh please foot shoulders there's only
one
there's only one clan for a foot soldier
how many feet do you have
two exactly so there's two clans no no
there's one foot in the
friend of me and there's two foot some
of them too yeah
okay i like impulsive i don't like their
new co-hosts
he's not funny how are you gonna going
to promote impulsive on our own podcast
i like it and i'm saying i just wish i
got another different co-host i hate all
their co-hosts
and mike should do it i just i got to
say that i feel like i always ride for
you
and now he's me to come to earth and
you're promoting impulsive
that hurts
it's not far off i'm not just the scum
of the internet you're kind of the scum
of the internet
it's not far off yeah oh trisha you're
doing me so dirty
thumb on the internet i feel like we're
both kind of at the bottom of the barrel
we scrape sometimes
i agree but like i would never wish harm
that's right
i don't think he wished har he says why
couldn't this happen to
oh man you know what tana
i'll i'll i'm gonna have to internalize
this and deal with this later okay you
know tana mon
mangu said frenemy's podcast is so good
ah we have to come for her
this week though i caught and that made
me so happy because i was like we texted
about it i was like oh tina's cool like
she said you know she doesn't care that
we talk [ __ ] about her i was just
impressed
because me and you both talk [ __ ] about
her yeah but she still had like she's
still like i'm down
i don't know she somehow still had like
the confidence to say i love this
podcast and i thought
that's pretty admirable i thought that's
really cool but did you see her at
nikita dragon's party this weekend
spitting in patrick starr's mouth ew god
help me jesus god help me god patrick
lord help me yes
and tana is like dodging it takes her
tongue out but then patrick stark kind
of catches the tongue with his tongue
you didn't see that clip the rumor is
there's a new
covid strain in la it's cut it was
caused from tana and patrick's are
making out
yeah it happened in that exact moment
okay also just a psa
people like nikita dragon showed her
kova test cool glad you did that you're
all supposed to keep your masks on and
be socially distant
after you get the cover test like that's
the whole thing with essential filming
first of all you're not essentially
filming you're at a party and there are
limits to that but if you were
essentially filming you still have to
keep your masks on and social distance
and everyone's masks were off
like what are these people are you guys
idiots like you should watch d'angelo's
video it's really good but you can't
support angela wallace
too much time on his hands yeah
impulsive better damn
look at this [ __ ] ring i see that
[ __ ] nine carrots
dude i'm gonna rob you if i ever go
broke i'm gonna rob you
[Laughter]
oh break time here let's pay for that
ring thank you to
adam and eve who sells apparently these
tiny little vibrators
on key chains disgusting shout out adam
and eve um yeah free stuff is awesome
but free stuff to spice up your sex life
even better they have stuff for guys
girls
couples games lingerie lotions and
potions and you can get it for 50
percent
ooh like okay there's like a i don't
know if i can say what words do i say
say it there's like a [ __ ] like
something for click cream to make it
more sensitive so it kind of like
like engulfs your clitoris they call it
a potion it's a little potion yeah
there's other little potions the potion
sounds like magical
there is it is that yeah and you can get
all this stuff for 50 people
there is yes okay good it actually you
spray it on the back of your throat and
it like numbs your throat and it's like
minty and then it numbs the
the member when it goes down your throat
what's the point of that so you just can
get more down
numbness mintiness there's people that
numb their throat so they can deep
throat
yeah oh my god that's great anyways you
can get a 50
potion or a lotion that's a potion oh
[ __ ] lotions are more like lube
code h3 you'll get 50 off plus free
shipping if you're in the us
50 off yeah and it also comes in this
group packaging which is pretty cool
plus you get
with this code i don't even get it with
my code with this code you actually get
free gifts you get like some free
movies you get free free spicy movies i
get for her
a gift for him and a third item you'll
both enjoy if you use the code h3
free shipping free shipping if you're in
the nation canada
code use the code h3 at checkout
adamandeve.com
they have a mini vibe for your keychain
it's the coolest thing ever it actually
works pops open so you have a little
mini vibe it goes on your keychain
do you take it you use it with your keys
attached or you take it off however you
want
that's just like how desperate are you
to forget your sometimes i'm desperate
if you're on that 405 and the 101
you do that while you're in the car holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] those are my only fans to be
popping in the car
oh you oh you do that on only fans can
you do live on only fans
yep oh that's cool you don't get as much
i get more on like tick tock live but
anyways
adam and eve you guys not only do they
have that they have this whole new bang
me series and the bang toys are awesome
they have these
giant vibe bullets they're like this big
and they're bullets bullets are like the
intense vibes and they have them now big
size can you imagine what either would
say to me if i was like hey eli got this
numbing agent that goes in the back your
throat so you can deep throughout my car
well you spray it back there you don't
think she can you imagine
i don't i think either would i i she
supports you
she does support me i feel like she'll
be down
you're supporting each other because it
helps her throat my nodules were
but i'm not i'm not trying to like i'm
not trying to like
you're past that do that much damage to
her that she needs numbing
right you know what i mean did you
already do that or are you just like
over it
i'm just saying if i ever did that i
wouldn't you never did
i'm saying if we ever did a sexual act
like that i think it's a phase
i wouldn't need to numb her throat
because of the damage i'm doing to her
that's like what you do in your surgery
and stuff fair enough
it's not like this it's not like this
you know what i mean well you don't have
to get thrown numbing cream you can get
toys you can get vibes
if you order now you can still get it in
time for valentine's day and super
fashion we love you
code h3
spicy movies you all know the drill go
to adamandeve.com
and use the code h3 the mini vibe get
the finger vibe
and they have a heart-shaped vibe right
now and i used to actually use it today
there's a heart shaped vibe in it and
and get
the perfect gift for any girlfriend
throat numbing cream
the most romantic gift you can buy a
girl well hey
girl or guy you can get it for your
partner maybe i'll get it for moses
right right whatever
you could use this any time you want
babe just spray it down oh my god
all right thank you we are back
i am recovering from that ad read i did
not know that you can numb the back of
the throat of your partner that's
hardcore
you ever use that maybe we should try it
for an episode and see who can get like
something down there throw like a
cucumber
i could never i can't my life my career
is over if i do that really
nobody needs gifts of me like jamming a
cucumber in the back of my throat
maybe the foot army or whatever you call
them foot soldiers foot soldiers don't
need that
we should do a foot soldier episode
let's compare feet maybe for an episode
guarantee you if we show our feet we'll
end up on our wiki page
i probably have a wiki feed page you
want to see what no let's go to this we
have other stuff
no let's see oh let's see let's see
trisha
paytas i can encourage the foot soldiers
to give you a good rating i don't really
need that
you think you utilize them for how you
want
trisha paytas net worth is the top one
let's see what it says
four million oh more what does net worth
mean
it's like how much money you have in
assets and cash and everything what are
you worth
four million i don't know i don't have
four million in my bank account no but
like of properties and stuff
you don't know how much you're worth no
or do you not just dude
i honestly don't know i never really i
don't really know what that means like
really how much money are you worth like
how much is in my bank account
no like if you if you sold everything
you own including
properties purses cars sure
purses like what what oh i don't know
instead of four million i'm making
payments on my house i don't really own
my house yet yeah but you put down
payments so you do own equity in it
okay cool i love that okay we're not
gonna we're not going anywhere with this
no i love that
how ironic like here i got your wiki
feet
trisha paid his feet holy [ __ ] you have
a really good rating really
oh you know what they do they don't show
the can you see this dan
let's see these photos oh my god look at
this what is this
you've never been on this website oh
thank god wow whenever you show your
feet they taking
who's this [ __ ] oh that's so old get
out of here
you got to start taking pictures of them
with you and moses with your feet
showing so that you can push his ass
down
damn yeah wow i show my feet a lot
so you haven't the last time you showed
your feet it was a that's an old one
yeah
you can tell by how my hair your weight
well no okay you just look younger i
don't know
i don't know what to tell you but but
yeah pretty good pretty good rating
congratulations thank you shoe size six
is that right
five oh see someone edit that edit it
actually it's like five and a half if
you want to be precise i'm number one on
the whole website
because you have your people i know it's
not funny i mean i don't know it's like
that funny
it's so [ __ ] funny all right let's
talk about jason whatever this show is
stupid
that why how are you going to argue that
me being number one on wikifeed isn't
hilarious
if you go to the website and sort by
most
highest rating i show up okay it's funny
thank you
it's hilarious okay so let's talk about
david now this is all new to me so i'm
really interested just
kind of watch all this and get your take
on it i'm excited to watch it and get
your take on it
since i don't know you know you're made
i made to believe that i'm like
such a crazy person that i can't keep
friends that everything i do is like
[ __ ]
toxic and nuts and i'm like i can't be
like that
nutty i mean i'm not you know like i did
go to the mental hospital three times
that year but i feel like
they made me that way because i like was
totally fine before i was kicking
okay okay so i've got i've got a bunch
of compilations one is just
david being problematic david
uh jason tana
oh with i guess he was trying to have a
threesome with tana all the time
jason calling you fat who was 18 at the
time that he tried to kiss her off
camera and she's like i didn't want it
it was so disgusting and then he kept
trying to like
have sex with her all right so he was 45
i'm like oh she's like 18 stop
so let's let's let's watch here let's
let's just start from the top here
now there was actually one part of this
compilation
where he tricks one of his friends into
making out with
jason in a mask which by the way is was
really disgusting
and then so we this whole compilation we
made got removed from the internet
and what and so david clearly has some
protocol
with his mcn with youtube where if
anyone uploads this clip
it automatically gets blocked which
leads me to believe
that david is in some form trying to
suppress
content that makes him look bad because
i know he did get a lot of [ __ ] for this
we did i do think we have that clip
regardless
oh how did we get it screen record i
think we have it
ew you know what my biggest problem with
him is like he never once acknowledged
anything any of this that nothing he did
was wrong ever like you can't just say
sorry that was gross like you can't just
say something and bpc
he just gets away with so much [ __ ] and
he's like
a really really problematic person like
an actually disgusting person like this
behind the scenes like trying to block
the stuff that you did like
so here it is so
and so the situation um it was really
it was quite mean he so this one of his
friends thought he was gonna be making
out with this girl
karina and so she goes into the bathroom
and she goes oh i don't look good and
then she goes back in and then jason
puts on this mask it was like an old
man's mask and then comes out and by the
way i don't know what's wrong with jason
he's like he needs to have some dignity
because like he literally does anything
for david
and he's an old [ __ ] man with kids
and he kind of needs to like have a
little bit of dignity
that was the greatest thing to me is
that like his like
i couldn't be around jason because i was
a bad influence on his kids like i
couldn't live with him because
i was like i'll take away your kids
meanwhile he lived with two other guys
that were banging chicks every night so
loud you could hear them [ __ ] in the
next room next to his kids live with
them
yeah he lived with them for like four
years jason lived with david
it was scott and todd and they were like
those guys
vlog squad people jason you live you
have a family
and his kids embarrass you we're right
next to todd's room where he'd be like
[ __ ] girls all the time they were
doing coke but i was the bad influence i
was like oh my god
he's so gross jason you he produced a
porn
like last year would david look alikes
and natalie look likes inside of david's
house and they like laughed about it on
the pot
like he's so disgusting what's even more
disgusting it's like they get away with
the [ __ ] right 18 she was 18 but now
he's hanging out with other 18 year olds
like the like charlie demilio and like
being like oh come like visit my dog
okay wait wait wait
wait stop you're so gross so anyway stop
hanging out with the sway house jason
you're 48.
so anyway to go back job
to go back to where i was so dave so
david
set up his friend to make out with jason
think he was making out with the girl
then the guy came out and said i i did
not have cons he didn't have my consent
he didn't tell me he was doing that it
was
it was not okay that he did that yeah
and so david now
is has a block in all territories
protocol
on that clip you can see right here so
actually i do want to show it
but i don't because like i'll dispute
him i don't care
but do we have it i mean i'd love to i'd
love to show it take this down
he'll take it he'll he'll try but come
on obviously he has some
people he'll try but can i
i've been through this this ain't my
first rodeo this is how awesome this is
we're watching it
in the block screen this is the only way
we can watch it and frankly i don't give
a [ __ ] david if you want to try to block
this
it's fair use i this is my first rodeo
this is we're going to watch it
and that's all this is going to happen
so sorry dude we're gonna we're and in
fact we're gonna watch it on the block
screen which is kind of epic
so here it goes this is a scary old man
mask that he's been using to scare
people for a while now i'm gonna
convince seth that he needs to make out
with karina while she's wearing that old
man
mask are you okay with making my parents
yes karina's gonna come out of my room
before she has the mask on and she's
gonna show me how weird she looks in her
outfit
i'm gonna tell her that it does look
weird and i need to go and add some more
padding to make her look more like an
old man i gotta put pat and you were
kind of dumb but instead of going to the
room and adding more padding karina is
going to hop out of the outfit and have
jason put it on his head
and stick to myself now
oh oh my god oh anyway
the guy gets freaked out when he
realizes jason
jason and jason really like made out
with him i'm like dude you have
no respect for yourself it's also
something kind of like
perverted about i don't know there's
something like not all together there
like i don't really know what it is
like he did that a lot they did a lot of
those kind of things like kiss my mom
like just like weird pervy stuff that i
was like
i don't know it's like the tana thing he
said it was a bit but the cameras
weren't rolling he's like oh i kissed
her in the closet she was i didn't want
it
and like she says that in the vlog and
david and dave was like oh that's gross
and it's like
it's just like ew i don't know i would
never do that put on a mask and make out
with another dude for a gag
when he thinks he's making out with the
girl i mean he just he's just desperate
so anyway here here that part we cut out
of this because
he blocked it so here's everything else
of david being problematic
maybe awkward at first but i'm sure
what's going on he's coming over he's
our only black friend don't ruin this
for me okay
this is alex you probably already know
[Music]
do you want
something to drink
come on out you guys like it's just like
straight up like a race like watermelon
is just the straight-up racist jokes
those are the jokes from like those old
cartoons that's like it's straight up
like
racist like there's nothing current like
new trendy funny nothing
this is the guy that he who made out
with
jason who later makes a video about it
i'll just i'll just watch live
do you want something to drink
come on out
long
i found out my friend seth has a warrant
for his arrest and this is because he
has a bunch of unpaid tickets so today
i'm gonna turn him into the police
station you're breaking the only friend
code there
really is seth yeah i'm just gonna be
pretty straightforward
it's like the [ __ ] they say is not that
funny no like he said
no but the heel like caught and like
okay everyone we're gonna come in with a
laugh whenever has to like laugh as if
like you said something
that's so fake how can you do that i
just i can't i could never do that
he really does that he would make what
would he tell you would he ever be like
you didn't laugh enough
no but he's like okay guys let's try
like he he read read stuff all the time
okay i'll try one time everyone just
like laugh more when she says this or
like something
that's so exhausting so phony this is
the same guy i don't want to keep
[ __ ] with this guy
this was like early on this was like
kind of before i was in the group i
didn't really know seth too well i met
him a couple of times but this was
before i wanted the police station to
turn you in i know that's what i thought
don't worry officers we got it from here
but you're joking right we're not going
to the police station with the amount of
overcrowding in jails right now
you'll get out in a couple weeks we're
here at the los angeles police
department
what the [ __ ] is going on bro want me to
go in with myself man
i'm not going in there i have warrants
oh this here it is
the stuff with with jason and and those
bits one
i did not consent to those things i did
not
david also shouldn't have done it period
it's
not right oh look at the japanese food
there we go first we're starting off
with um
it's not racist that's like the sounds i
hear when they talk no it's not racist
as long as i keep saying no
oh okay
i give this one five sushi rolls out of
eight people
i know i just have to keep saying no now
we're gonna try this one
i think it's called dominion i love
shooting people in different ethnicities
yeah man i want to shoot some black
people
oh we're cops oh gotcha
[Applause]
[Music]
so you've been seeing this girl for a
month around a month yeah do you love
her
[ __ ] off is brandon good at sex honestly
yeah
she's 17. hell yeah brandon what's up
[Laughter]
what anyway she listened to jason's
party because she wasn't 18. like i knew
about this that's why i started distance
myself
and jason would always be pissed at me
that i wouldn't film with brandon i'm
like he's an actual like pedophile and
we're actually like and he's like 24.
having sex with a cemetery isn't
pedophilia it's pedophilia for sure
with a minor for sure was
that's an actual pedophile like it's a
child 17 year olds as a child
so okay whatever i don't need to debate
that but it's illegal
um well pedophile someone that has sex
with kids
she's a child that's a child but you
don't magically become not a child when
you go
turn from when the clock ticks that
actually is like how it works yeah
like you also have no business being
like an 18 year old but like 17 is an
actual child you're actually it's
actually legal like you actually should
go to jail
okay i'm not here to debate that but
some states it's 16. but it's not that
in california
i know it's illegal it's f and also old
guys shouldn't be creeping on 17 year
olds
okay so anyways where are we going with
it
so in response to this is um
so on that the the tricking the guy into
kissing was
was really twisted he's blocking it so
he's obviously afraid of the criticism
which is
interesting the racist jokes and stuff i
i mean i just i don't think it was like
super
super super bad just you know kind of in
bad taste
i don't think it's like i mean i don't
know i don't really have a comment i
think it's like i think it's bad but i
also think you should take like
accountability everyone else has to
you just can just like skip i mean other
people did less like jenna marbles like
had to like leave it
in shame and this is all right big thing
for me was that saying that he didn't
consent to it which is
really why i made my final video exiting
from that group [ __ ] up
he specifically called me and jason and
said can i use the bit where tana comes
over and jason tries to [ __ ] her and i
was like no
jason says no i'm on the phone with
david at 2am
he posted his vlog anyways it happens
i'm like crying and blowing my eyes out
he's like it won't happen again two days
later it's just him jason madison beer
and tana and they do that exact same
joke again and i laughed when i lost my
[ __ ] i'm like i'm making a [ __ ] video
i did not consent to it i said i was
uncomfortable
you pushed hannah to do this joke and
tana's like i don't wanna he's like i
remember this so clearly when tana came
over to the house
when i said don't invite her he's like
can you guys just go in the room and
jason takes his shirt off and you guys
like pretend like you're having sex and
she's like no
i'm not doing that like we said no so
many times and like he just
wouldn't take no for an answer he's so
consent thing is like disgusting to me
so i'm not i was so
uncomfortable like so uncomfortable and
i said it
i'm not super familiar with the tana
situation so i'm just gonna this is the
clip that kind of talks about but from
what i gathered briefly
is that he kept trying to
well i'll just play this this is why i
don't like the legality loophole because
jason's 44 in this clip
tana's 18 and he like tried to make kiss
her and tana's like i didn't want it why
did you do it the cameras weren't on
and everyone's like well she was legal
she was an adult but she's clearly
saying she was uncomfortable didn't want
it he's 44
no that's disgusting that's a that to me
should be a pedophile because that's a
child you're a grown ass man yes it's
not legally a pedophile but it's
so i'm just saying people misuse the
word pedophile he's still pedophile
someone
like [ __ ] like an eight-year-old okay
he's still making but he's creepy and
predatory
there's a tick-tock house with only
eight-year-old eight to 13 year old and
he made a video with them i forget what
they're called it's on his thing
and it's like why there's a tick tock
house with eight-year-olds are you for
sure it's a 13 year old and he did a
whole video trying to beat in their
house what's the name of that tick tock
house
if you type i'm sure if i pedal house oh
my god i thought we were not saying the
p word and he's like let's look what i'm
saying is like
and he goes under the guise and this is
what happens and i'm i'm not saying
jason is this i'm saying for
my abuser he went under the guys i'm a
father i have a daughter her age so it's
totally fine it's not totally fine
it's creepy and disgusting you have no
right being around young children like
that
like it's not acting it's not set like
the parents i mean they could have been
around they might not have been around
but
this is like real life this is vlogs but
they disguise all of this as we're
acting it was a bit
the thing with the minor the 17 year old
and the 24 year old oh that was just
acting they didn't really have sex
[ __ ] that was real oh that was real
but okay so here so here's where the
friction happened is that
david kept playing up this angle that
jason wanted to
have sex with tana or to have a
threesome and it was actually starting
to cause problems in your relationship
this particular clip is before we even
met like he really didn't want to date
tana he tried to hang out with her so
this was before we even met dude that's
okay you're 44 and you're trying to make
up with the 18 year old bro stop
stop that's disgusting and he did it
while the cameras are off and they admit
to all of this
jason i mean with peace and love jason i
don't know you but you're really
embarrassing from what i can tell it's
embarrassing and like it's just it's
creepy doesn't he feel like doesn't he
just feel a little bit humiliate he must
feel humiliated by david like david
perpetually humiliates him and you told
me before
you were recording that on their podcast
jason only gets 10
they do a podcast together yeah and
david's like you only get 10 percent
yeah maybe it's changed maybe now that
jason has more but
i don't know it's humiliating yeah
beyond just paying
making less money it's just humiliating
to pay him 10 percent
this was my favorite thing during i'm
right jason don't you have any software
go ahead show me i have to see it show
me that jump
we're all getting canceled for their
racist jokes including jason and david
they bring in king bach they bring in
two people that are never in their vlogs
so uh dan pull up this clip
so you so what is what's the context
with this clip uh
oh you can you put wait oh okay you play
for me now then daniel shut up
put you in the wheelchair jeff got shot
did you know that
you got shot jeff come on in here let me
see that bruise
we were peacefully protesting we were
riding i wasn't there [ __ ] looting
smashing upstairs
too
[Laughter]
look at their reactions compared to
jason okay so he's talking about being
at a peaceful protest and getting shot
with one of those like pellets or
whatever
jason's and him are like laughing at it
like these two guys also they're never
in the vlog king bash i'm sorry i forget
this guy's name he was on the reality
show house i forget his name
but they're like they bring him in
during the black lives matter i think
they're all getting canceled for
something else and he's like we need to
talk the video is called it's time for a
change
and so he brings in these two guys that
are never in the videos african-american
whatever
and then they proceed to talk about jeff
like caucasian being like shot and like
just like laughing at it you can just
see like from this guy's expression
versus like jeff and him like laughing
and this guy's like what the [ __ ] like
you got
like you know what i mean like it's a
serious [ __ ] anyways it's all cringy too
because these are guys that are never in
the vlogs
they're all getting cancelled for being
racist which they were in past vlogs
with seth and other people
and it's like oh you know what i'm gonna
bring two african-american guys in here
to just kind of like
i'm not racist if i if i can be devil's
advocate i feel like
they're just hearing it for the first
time and jason and jeff
but what's funny about being shot by
police at a protest like why are they
laughing what's the
there's there's comedy and everything i
mean but what is it i would love to know
like what's funny during black lives
matter being shot by like
because you're white it's like he was
there protesting like like if it was a
black guy being shot like it's not funny
it's not funny if anyone's being shot
like why are you laughing because you're
white and you could you survived it
no tell me i would i really would love
to know because i don't i don't really
get it
yeah i mean you can laugh just because
you're laughing at something doesn't
mean that you think it's funny
what oh okay so it's just like what i'm
like genuinely curious i'm not like mad
i'm just like genuinely curious what it
is
i don't know i'm just i'm just i i don't
necessarily see
everything you see there but let's watch
this okay
let's watch this okay here we go
recently went on a date they were in a
dressing room i don't know why they were
in a dressing room together but jason
was getting changed and jason thought
that there was a spark in the air why
would she come in the dressing room
dressing what we were doing why would
you come into it
and then this is the best part jason
leans in for a kiss
you're not giving all the information oh
yeah you're right you're you're right
you're right
that's disgusting like that's not
funny and she's like i i don't know if i
said it in that clip there's some
probably at the end of this clip she's
like literally like i didn't want it the
cameras were off and he's like
laughing about it and even david's like
it's gross the fact that he needs to
repeat
this and then they do this huge laugh
like she's 19 year old and he tried to
lean in for a kiss
yeah it's like you're like a predator
okay so now here
is uh entice me as much tana just called
actually she wanted it
[Laughter]
again not interested i didn't make the
joke
guys chill this is the stupidest [ __ ]
fight ever she doesn't like town jokes
drop it so did you actually get replaced
on this phone
so so give me some insight to you i take
my clothes off i take my clothes off in
this bit like i [ __ ] go i lose my
shack completely why did you take your
clothes off
because i didn't want him to use it in
the in the vlog i'm like if i get
completely naked he can't use it you'll
see he like leaves it in and like blurs
it out
um like when it was an actual thing
where we told him like this is not funny
like and they didn't make it for a while
you said do not include this so he did
this for months and this is like the
final time when we really blew up and i
don't [ __ ] do those jokes
he stopped until he needed to get me out
of the vlog squad so this is my thing he
tried to start kicking me out of the
vlog squad
with like old david he's like we need to
get trisha out when like these old
this old video of me saying i support
trump's surface right i said like
immigrants are stealing our job some
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] that like
it's stupid whatever and it came out
obviously david's uh
daca or whatever and so that's when he
started like being like we're not
filming with trish i would go over and
he's like trish you stay in the car like
started he used to film with me every
single day
and i get it okay fine distance yourself
from me like whatever i'm
problematically telling you to stay in
the car
yeah stopped filming with me so this was
like all right what does that mean he
would tell you to stay in the car like
you would go somewhere yeah like we
always went around like and everybody
would get out and he would say stay in
the car
yeah huh whatever i mean i get it i was
like did he ever do that to anybody else
like the boring ones like carly and
aaron they always had it like stay back
we started using them after i left
because like the girls
what kind of world is this where he's
telling people to stay in the car i mean
this is funny
i guess you know whatever it's
problematic it was old tweet a old video
of me whatever
and so he's he's trying to start
distancing me like getting me out of the
vlogs whatever it's again i'm not even
mad about that
but what was so crazy is he knew this
week before i might blow up that's when
he started doing the tana he invited tan
over to the house to have sex with tana
he released footage that jason never
wanted in the vlog where jason said
privately to him
at like a party if you can get tana to
have sex with me like i'll buy you a
ferrari because that was like
david's dream car and like all this [ __ ]
he started putting in the vlogs the week
of my blow up and i was like
i was holding it in i was holding it and
i just lost so he knew
that you were not comfortable with these
jokes because it made you
feel insecure rightfully so i mean
that's your boyfriend it's not even
insecure it made him look like a pervert
like i'm like i'm dating this like
pervert that wants to be with like it
makes everyone look and feel bad i don't
mind a threesome i've had threesomes
like you know
buying trish.com with adam and lena we
sell it like i don't mind like i'm not
insecure about it no but she's she's 19.
i don't want us to go in a room with
jason this 19 year old and like she's
uncomfortable with it i was just like
and tana's a clout right she just wants
anything for david's vlog she's like
and even that she was like nah yeah no
she really watched but i'm not doing
that i'm not doing it and they kept
pushing and pushing it was so
so was jason in on the pushing or was he
also telling david i'm not coming
to jason's defense he was cuz he was
dating me and at the time he's kind of
like i don't know
even that night he's like i want to put
that on the vlog and david puts it in
the vlog
that's so [ __ ] yeah but jason so both
you
and jason are saying both saying david
don't put this in the vlog
yeah and he does i still remember it was
like 2 a.m he calls jason like can i put
this and i'm like no and then jason's
like no don't
and then he did and then he did it again
a second time that week and i don't want
my [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's really great he's so gross
anyways okay well here there's a lot
more yeah
surprising vibe crew is what it is these
send this i gotta see this
that's just yeah play for me
oh send me on whatsapp i gotta see the
vibe crew
wait hold on let me finish this let me
finish this vibe crew
okay hang on here we go
i'm not in this room i'm like sleeping
at home or something like i'm not in
this
she's 19 and nobody wants this threesome
nobody wants it it's so gross tana will
do it because she's broken and one's
clout and
i felt bad for her because i see me like
at 19 i let people do
crazy [ __ ] put a candle stick up my ass
whatever anything for like a little bit
of money a little bit of cloth whatever
and so she would do it and i'm gonna
love it i i broken
whenever you mentioned the candlestick i
just i was 19 i was panicking
bro and so i i see the same brokenness
in her and she'll invent
you feel he's taking advantage so taking
advantage and maybe now she's like i
love it uh whatever but like
literally when she's my age she's gonna
be in a mental hospital as well like
it's sad because
something does make you go a little nuts
like you use your abuse
and you don't realize it at the time it
sucks
yeah why do you want to be on twitter
your children are on your channel
you're so disgusting why are you aren't
there i agree
and people are like you're so obsessed
with it it's like he's still on the
internet collabing with a tick tock
house of 13 year olds and i've seen
we're going to watch that
that's uncomfortable and i'm going to
call it out just like brandon calvio
should not be around
this is for me no this is for me because
i'm i'm new to all this stuff so
patricia is educating me this stuff
triggers me but i agree with it because
these are actual there's like some
there's some disgusting behavior that
i've seen patterns of in my past and i
think it's disgusting
i put
you can't run to trisha with this piece
of video and be like jason said jason
said damn it
trisha can you help me with my video you
would do anything for me
can you and jason have a threesome with
tana
i think she's in australia
where are you i just got off the plane
now earlier
like i know you and jason did but do
other people in the club be like david
yeah
don't do this yeah it's proven um
there's been in vlogs actually where
corinna was like blowing todd in a in a
in his tesla and they begged him not to
use it like you can't use that [ __ ]
footage you can't use it
he like said i'll pay you like a
thousand dollars if you let me use it
and they're like no and they're like
i'll pay you five thousand like okay
fine but they like
people have expressed like that they
don't want in the vlog and he'll like
have to either
sometimes he'll take it out i've seen
him take it out he's never taken it out
for me or he'll like
say i'll pay you or something if i can
put it in the blog
jesus yeah i don't want to hang around
with this guy you know what i mean it's
like this guy is [ __ ] just looking to
leech
everybody's life force out for his
[ __ ] dumbass vlog
yeah yeah so it's easy for him he's
behind the camera he's never have to
deal with me
yeah the subject of his [ __ ] you're
here
this is our ass okay you know i'm like
taken though right
sure whatever okay because i just like
you're about to ask me to [ __ ] someone
no okay um would you ever throw someone
with jason trisha
how do you feel about jason wanting to
have a threesome with you but why me
jason
because he likes broken girls
is that true or true yes why are you in
a tesla at midnight while i'm [ __ ]
sleeping with like tana and stuff like
that
by the way i lost my [ __ ] when i saw it
he didn't even tell me and david and
jason were like oh we were gonna run by
you we forgot
[ __ ] you i'm doing a whole exposed video
you [ __ ] are a pedo enabler you're
doing all this crazy [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
i've never laughed once in my life like
that
you couldn't be in the vlog squad then
yeah i gotta work on that
okay so so this this is disgusting why
the [ __ ] do these eight-year-olds have a
hype house
it's called the vibe crew welcome back
i love sports i love basketball and i
collect baseball cards
and it's great to be a part of the vibe
crew
wait how old is this guy i'm actually
not sure
did you get the wrong guy indeed i think
so indeed um
i don't know this is who i thought was
coming your name
hey i just want to say i'm super excited
about the vibe crew olympics today
i can't guys we got new merch
that's right i need to be hanging out
with like miners like
you just like don't need it for a vlog
he has he must have so much
mixed emotions about david because it's
like david's
moved on and so jason's forced to be
doing [ __ ] like this for 120 000 views
getting 10 of a podcast that he's part
half of
and like god he must really he must hate
i feel like deep down jason must hate
david true or false yeah true for sure
because when we were like sneak like
sneak talking because david's like you
have to cut trisha off and he's like i
have to cut you off sorry david told me
and then whatever he like until we still
hang out for like three months whatever
until he like went to a mental hospital
again
but he would he would tell me he's like
oh i just don't want to go to like
a club to go see kylie jenner like
they're trying to track kylie jenner
down at like
dre's or whatever the club i don't even
know the clubs and he's like i [ __ ]
hate this so
like he's like just such a like fake
person you like
yeah david's 24 years old yeah
yeah he's really young they met when he
was 18 and jason was 42. imagine being a
40 year old man and an 18 year old
telling you have to break
what is with david he's like a cult
leader literally
did you hear what he said to me in that
clip trisha you do anything for me right
and i'm like yeah what how many why i
would never ask
dave i don't know what it's so weird
it's crazy how
uh they're all embarrassing they're all
so embarrassing
it's so weird he has such a
tight rule on that whole party yeah
but nobody ever or do people expose him
but nobody cares nobody
holds anything against david because
he's just laffy he's just a laffy fun
guy he
laughs and everything is fun i don't
know what it is about him that he gets
to escape it but one day he's gonna be
turned i said this i called it gonna
turn like a ted bundy and then people
are like oh we should be like no
something he's psycho like he's an
actual i feel like he's
not to say sociopath yeah let's
let's not use that word shane said he
was a sociopath maybe he's an empath
he's i don't know david is so careful
he's so buttoned up and tight like
well now yeah he just stopped vlogging
he hasn't posted in like a year like
he's just done on youtube i guess but
which was honestly i'm happy he did that
because of coved very responsible
to give him credit yeah well no after
after my shenanigan like the thing where
i exposed him he stopped putting any
like sexual jokes all of a sudden now he
became like the guy that gave away money
like
it was so weird because he's really good
at following the trend
because mr beast was like mr give it
away and
mr beast is like king of youtube and
people think like if you give away money
you're like the nicest guy like dude
gives money away so like trisha [ __ ] you
and i was like it's obviously
a person well it's nice that he's doing
it but it's
obviously he's doing it for the trend
for sure yeah
i give away a hundred thousand thousand
give me [ __ ] anything i should have
monetized that better
give a hundred thousand dollars i didn't
get [ __ ] [ __ ] out of that i didn't
get view i didn't even
put in a video
that's one of my biggest regrets in life
is not monetizing that better
i mean i could yeah i'm not even kidding
we donated by the way speaking of nice
oh where's our proof we i spent it in
the group chat did we
dan where's the proof you donated 2000
to planned parenthood in 2000
transequality.org
so trisha so okay we did we did planned
parenthood trans equality because of
last week i got dominated
was that last week and pop culture
trivia
now i don't know why you went and
donated 2 000 to both of our charities i
don't know if you're going to so i'm
like let's just do it to be safe
of course i'm going to well i didn't
think that you would not i just like you
know what let me just it was my idea
well you're very
you're very um i just wanted to do it
you're very charitable you're very
charitable
so and then i was like well so i donated
a thousand to each charities
yeah proof showed the receipts receipts
[ __ ] we got the receipts
we're [ __ ] the best people in the
world we donate money
pretty much every episode just show it
in post
but just so you know we giving out money
we're not even doing it for clout or any
weird [ __ ] we're just
good ass people i gave away 30 000 last
year for my 32nd birthday so
are you serious you are such a good
person
what'd you give it to i did i did 10 000
to followers i gave
500 to eat to 20 people um for that
i did transit quality.org i did doctors
without borders oh great um
i did broadway cares equity fights yeah
i divided it up and i raised awareness i
think like i said the main thing wait
you didn't give away tesla
did you give away tesla though
did you give away a twitch left for
followers no ah
not that nice then are you bro i could
have
i could have given away three teslas
with that hundred thousand dollars can
you imagine
this sucks elon musk is a that's right
i have a tesla i like my tizzy wait okay
stop
let's not derail dan okay stop i'm still
doing this whole jason thing on
jason and david wallace can you do an
expose on this he's more research than
us i feel like
you don't even like
so jason and tana j now here's what
clips of jason calling you fat is that
okay to watch
but it's so crazy because is this fair
like is this something you want to watch
it was awful
but then when like seth is calling us
out like everyone's just like wow cloud
chasers all that stuff it's like i'm not
big nick called him out i'm not the only
person who's
uncomfortable with david like that's so
weird that he gets away with this stuff
like it's insane so wait what's the
so jason was rude to you and calling you
fat like what is this jason like
just made fun of my food and my weight
the whole time just told me to like calm
down on eating
this is more just about jason being a
dick and not really about david he just
always commented on my food
he just had an issue with me eating all
the time again which is weird because
you would think if you're dating trisha
paytas you're in for the whole package
right i mean but like i mean anyone
who's like dating me or knows me like i
don't really eat that much like i think
it looks like a lot online because i
piece things together from like
different days but like
i don't eat that much in one sitting
like i'm not really like no it's a big
fat piece of [ __ ]
i don't exercise and i'm older and i eat
fast food but
i like happy meals what were we talking
oh
did he slap your hand away from nachos
okay so yeah let's why this is jeffrey
stars that i slandered him by saying
that he didn't make fun of people
renting houses and then there's
literally a podcast clip from the sip he
doesn't know what
there is and i but there's literally a
clip of him saying no i know i just i
buy my house
you literally make fun of people anyway
also this he's an idiot
an idiot you know i think we need to
slow down on the food
that is like maui
i do remember i got an ice cream and and
that's what we're going to go do next
and jason not much has changed jason
judged me for having an ice cream at
noon
still to this day anything about you can
have ice cream i didn't say anything
oh no we have to get it for the thing
but i can't eat it in front of you but
we have to get it for the vlog
oh okay can we can we talk about this
please can you please drop this shirt
yogurt see i think what's going on this
is what i think what's going on
i think secretly you're using this this
hunger strike thing
you're like gonna blame me but in the
meantime you're gonna like lose weight
and look hot
i think i think that's what's going on
now no i'm like starving and miserable
like i
hate it and eat something i told you
i'll never comment on anything again
guys this is what happened i wouldn't
even give you the credit of if i lost
weight i would not give that to you and
be like jason
you wouldn't give me the credit but
you'd be looking you're looking hot as a
size lower
he doesn't really look hot
i don't
without you i eat before
so anyway um there's more so he calls
you fat
david and jason run around la making
racist comments well dressed as native
americans
oh that's like a different thing too i
mean they just did a bunch of races [ __ ]
and he gave apparently a really celici
david dobrik rarely deletes videos and
one of them jason nash dressed as native
americans who runs around la making
racist jokes at passer buyers
video was scrubbed from the internet see
that's what i was saying about the kiss
when david gets into [ __ ] he scrubs and
he puts block
protocols with his mcn which is you know
interesting is it possible to find any
screenshot or video
wow and but here's his apology
apparently which is an awful apology
let's see i think was too offensive but
after reading
hey what's up guys a lot of you guys are
wondering why i have to delete my last
vlog and that's because i made an
offensive joke that at the time i didn't
think was too offensive but after
reading some comments i realized that a
lot of you guys didn't like it as much
as i thought you were going to for those
of you guys who found the vlog to be
offensive i'm sorry you did for those of
you who didn't find it to be offensive
i'm sorry they did so instead of
completely deleting this vlog that's a
little insensitive
what a great apology i'm sorry they did
it basically well what he's doing is
he's blaming them
he's like it's if you sorry if you
didn't get to see the video it's these
[ __ ]
sensitive [ __ ] faults they're just
ah you like that dan should i use that
next time i get into hot water
i'm sorry they got offended for those of
you who weren't offended i'm sorry that
they did get offended
can we sound like that have zach
have zach wait we have to have zach
sound bite that
okay much as i thought you were going to
for those of you guys who found the vlog
to be offensive i'm sorry you did for
those of you who didn't find it to be
offensive i'm sorry
they did so instead of completely
deleting this vlog i decided there's a
lab
squad dance laugh right there dan you
would fit right in i guess they do laugh
that hard
i'm just fine dan honestly just thinks
i'm [ __ ] hilarious really and the
cake decorating you're like no
[ __ ] well just because he thinks i'm
funny doesn't mean they just eat that he
knows anything
we didn't even watch that yet what is
this
i apologize for that i feel like i've
made enough offensive jokes on youtube
where i've kind of figured it out now
anyway
i mean look i'm i do find the whole
reports of like how controlling he is
behind the scenes disturbing
it's more like hey if someone's
uncomfortable with something like how
about you just you know
drop it yeah maybe just don't put it in
your stupid vlog that no one cares about
anymore like you know but he is fl
it is a whole power dynamic where like
he knows that people
need or want to be there so bad that he
is able to make them do things that they
would otherwise and most they wouldn't
they don't they don't want to do
yeah that's [ __ ] up right but jason
used it as excuse to like oh i can hit
on young girls because it's like a bit
for david jason has no dignity he's
basically a dog
literally yeah i mean i feel bad for
jason in a way because he's basically
been cut
i hate this word but honestly it's so
appropriate cucked by 18 year old
cocked by everybody in his life maybe so
like i wish he had a little dignity but
i guess when he has dignity he's making
a lot less money
yeah i guess so i don't know
i mean yeah anyway what do i know about
interesting stuff
oh um stay away from miners you don't
need to belonging with them
the [ __ ] i just don't need to be even
if it's innocent like what was that in
the house
wait but i don't think the vibe house is
real no the bypass is real
it's so no it's real can you look that
up moses that was like a parody like
video but it's that is that the real
vibe house i don't believe it
he was doing like the sway house the
bypass like he was doing all these
somebody tell me
the vibe house please god don't let this
be real
please god please don't let this be
with a bunch of real though this only
has 65 000. no there are tick-tockers
the vibe house is a tick-tock
i'll show you you send me a shirt please
god don't let this be real please
please please i'm begging please god
well i mean here he is with the lopez
brothers so that just just
he deleted his videos with the lopez
brothers but still has the tick tock cup
oh those lopez brothers gotten some [ __ ]
huh
and they're still on tank top and the
one lopez brother did the tick tock
going live
lives lives like he didn't think about
it dude how is it that both of them are
like
end of 14 year olds i don't know 17 was
bad so the mom
the mo yeah 14 that's that's bad
that's very bad like bendy
try to blame the girls the manager put
out an official statement saying like
well they were scammed they lied about
their age
14. that's like that's like being
that's like saying of an eight-year-old
listen she lied about her age
[Laughter]
it's like dude but was like i'm settling
about the
did you watch the video of the mom yeah
well weird was like let's watch that can
you
uh moses i'm sorry to employ you now but
can you pull that up
or dan go ahead uh there's one with the
mom
uh recording talking to what's his name
this was andreas lopez no i thought it
was the other one tony was the other
brother this is the new one oh he's
supposed
to oh tripped me out oh and andre yes
so he apparently had sex with a 14 year
old and the mom called him
not sex well we don't know what the
relationship was we had an inappropriate
relationship but we don't know what the
extent of it
he hooked up with 14 year old the mom
was recording the phone call where he
basically
admitted he did admit to it yeah and um
and the mom is just like epic [ __ ] w
yeah this is it
i got the mom yeah this is a famous tick
tock guys these were like the guys
dancing with d james charles and
everything and
they're super big they're in everyone's
videos and they're all hype house are
they twins those two
no oh but they're both [ __ ] around
with young girls it's like their thing i
guess but
that's so weird two of them here so this
mom [ __ ] his whole life up
and you are home
okay damn she gotta flex with the gucci
in this
even it's like lady come on we're
talking about something serious
why you gotta flex the gucci box and you
are home
23. yeah you know what can happen to you
i do i can't hear it dan you can end up
in jail
you go to jail i do realize that
we need to talk in person i'm bringing
my daughter with me
and my sister and we need to figure this
out
okay i'm totally okay with that when can
we meet
um whenever
he's just hoping he's not going to get
in trouble by she's recording very dumb
ass
yeah but also why isn't she going like
the police why is she putting the victim
and the abuser in the same room like
it's just like a lot like i wouldn't
bring my daughter
she's like i'm gonna bring my daughter
and we're gonna talk it out like talk
about she did it please
they haven't gone to the police i
haven't filed a police report well all i
know is that she got him to confess
basically i guess yeah i mean no that is
a huge thing like that's
i do hope she didn't bring her daughter
though because i wouldn't do that
um they're disgusting and the fact that
they saw the tick tock channel and like
people james charles was trying to
defend them oh was he
on twitter just trying to be like
there's two sides to every story
okay calm down okay sister also did you
see this
charlie amelia she's like i'm looking
through the hashtag here for charlie
this happened today
and oh my goodness you all are so sweet
and you have no idea how much your kind
words were my heart
and it was for actually charlie xcx she
her producer passed away so everyone's
like here for charlie but she thought it
was for her and she was like
thanking everybody but it was like that
her producer just passed away and it was
not charlie demilio
how embarrassing she's so self-absorbed
i
i she needs to be like grounded
did you see the boa wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait stop stop stop stop
wait
wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa some
person named charlie c-x
not her a famous is a famous charlie
whose producer passed away
yeah people were sending her well wishes
here for charlie was the hashtag
and she thought it was about her yeah
and all the all the tweets
and show me what she tweeted that is so
[ __ ] i'm looking through the here for
charlie hashtag and oh my goodness
you all are so sweet you have no idea
how much your words were in my heart i'm
so lucky to have you by my side i love
you boobs
and then someone's like that is so
embarrassing they're like man this is so
messed up if you had actually clicked on
the hashtag and actually read it you
would have known it's for charlie xcx
because her great friend and
collaborator sophie just passed away in
tragic circumstances this is the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to a human being
and now did she erase it real fast she
erased it but now she was trending
because
of that so everyone was like what i
don't like i don't like making fun of
charlie because she's a 16 year old girl
and she's blameless she's
living in a mad world with crazy parents
but i mean just
all that in a vacuum that's the most
embarrassing thing i've ever heard
happen to anybody maybe like
get off like the internet she's i'm so
tired of the 16 they're letting her go
to bow about herself and then do
paparazzi interviews and stuff like that
like get her under control
i can't stop she literally
i can't believe that happened somebody
died and they and she was
she just thought people were wet wishing
her well it's trend it's still trending
number one fantastic
yeah this is a day oh my god fans
clarify that the here for charlie
hashtag was meant for charlie xcx after
the death of a friend
it's insane
god holy [ __ ] these girls need did you
see
oh bro that's i feel like you can never
get over that in your whole life
like you you accepted the condolences
for somebody else thinking it was just
people saying that they support you
um it's un unheard of
she's 16 though but wow they need to
like take her off to
talk and put her back in school or
something it's insane
although her boyfriend did comment on my
tick tock really
little huddy left a comment on my do you
know a little honey yeah i know of
little huddy of course who doesn't know
little lottie
yeah little hottie commented on one of
my
i wonder if he knows me does he know
that i like come for
like what did he say was it nice um
i can't remember i don't know the
context if it was nice though i know i'm
trying to find it the way you don't it
was cryptic like you didn't understand
what he meant
how old is the little hoodie he seems he
just turned 18 that's why they had to
break up because she was 15 and he was
dating her at 17 and he turned 18 so
like we gotta break up now
yes please here it is i got eight
million views on it and i i want to
thank little huddy i think cause he
commented on it i got a lot of
interaction
really a comic can do that yeah it has
eight million views on this one
the hud story oh he's down here
that's his comment okay trisha okay
trisha well let me see
look at all the comments underneath it
wait i have over three thousand
let me see the tick tock what is it
finally oh you mentioned him
it's a song finally little hoodie makes
a song
tell me what you hear at the end what's
the last word he says ready go ahead
what'd you pull it up it's backwards oh
he says i'm a vampire
oh so you know the song you hear me yeah
he said i'm a 21st century
tampon so i held up like i have seen the
title
i said i want to say i started this
because i've never seen anyone do the
tampon thing like i literally heard that
i was like oh it sounds like
like he just said okay trisha so is he
like supporting like
okay trisha no i think it was i think
number one
yeah i'm a south i'm number one oh i
fell babe
i think i think on one hand he's happy
people are using a song
do you think he like knows that i like
don't like dixie and charlie
come on but like he's like dating them
and like going to the bahamas with them
i think it was meant to be passive
aggressive but at the same time he was
happy that you were using a song
right so he wanted it to be cryptic but
at the same time he wanted it to get
views
it's a whole there's a whole there's a
lot of different plays with that 8
million views thank you for that that's
eight times more than i did and it's
good for him too because his song
i like to think about how to be like
okay trisha that's how i picture i'm
saying it
definitely not i think that was it was
like okay trisha
it's better than being like okay trisha
like enough you're harassing me like at
least it's better than that
it could have been that okay i'm gonna
go with the happy one little heavy
lettuce okay
trisha fan i'm not i don't really know
anything about him i like it
you like the hut the pizza hut oh we're
supposed to get domino's this episode
maybe next time
the hut okay that's it we have it that's
it oh one other one other thing before
the cake off can we show them
is that uh i just want you to know that
jeffree star
after disavowing hair by jay liked
tagged him in a post
like yesterday i mean that's like actual
trash sticking together so good job here
i'll show you
at least they're not miners at least
they're not with like children that are
13 years old oh here
here by jay wow
great i mean he literally just
disappointed this is from
from two days ago jeffrey's last video
didn't even hit a million views in like
24 hours like it's no one cares anymore
like they were literally so done like
drama used to help him
wait i thought jeffrey was super popular
if you see it like 9 million views of
video i think the last one just hit like
a million
no way is it at
oh wow 900 why are people not watching
his videos
it's just like they're over it this is
like i got cancelled again so i had this
is the one where he said i was
slandering him in it which was like i
know you actually
said that he doesn't even know it's
slander and like it's just gross like
he's like i got canceled again no you're
a shitty person i'm not trying to cancel
you you'll never be canceled you're just
a [ __ ] person
any accountability because all of his
other views were clocking
but clocking look under a million
like that's the same one but still like
his old ones used to get like 9 million
you watch people's views don't you know
i love it i don't do that
i feel like it's not good for the soul i
love it when it's people like i said i
like white
watching people's demise when they're
actually [ __ ] people like if they're
[ __ ] people like yeah yeah but also then
that means you're like you're following
your own numbers so closely and it's
just oh no i literally never know my i
swear on my youtube videos like i'm
always like
i just really you just hate it you just
hate watch people
yeah okay i love it you track our views
you always tell me about it oh well for
sure if i'm in it i gotta say no but you
track our other views too like why don't
you compare myself to how i'm helping
this channel
i watch the subscribers go up i'm like
okay i think that that's some parsley
because
how's your channel doing i haven't
checked i'm stagnant
no way i'm not getting anything your
channel's popping no it's definitely not
you just told me you made a like
shitload of money from me from your
december
the h3 drama thank you you're welcome
see it goes both ways yeah so okay wait
your channel's
stagnant i thought you were popular i
always say the same i think i'm shadow
band
yeah shadow band yeah that's fine look
i just want to move on oh is that about
me yeah oh one point one nice
i'm scared of oh see those ones are good
too you got more than him [ __ ]
eat [ __ ] jeffree star [ __ ] keep having
hair by j in those overpriced ways
you're gonna go broke
don't wish it on you don't want bad
karma but you know good luck
i wish everyone well [ __ ] it i don't
know everybody changing it
everyone what happened in 2021 yeah yeah
that lasts for like two days
20 21 to shot keep your channels going
the one that said i rate my boyfriend
whatever
that's what's going to feed yourself no
that's slander
jeffrey star take note saying you raped
your boyfriend
that girl needs money okay it's bad
karma to you it comes back
oh you want to go bake a cake you want
to go bake a cake i want to bake a cake
and eat it too
all right let's go do the bake off all
right let's go to the kitchen
hi i'm chef ethan and i'm the co-chef
trish and i'm the hedgehog you're not
the kosher
you're just a chef in your own rice okay
i'm the sous chef
no you're not sushi you're your own sous
chef is assistant chef
okay you're us you're just beer you're
be it
own it girl i've been a chef before at
betty hannah's you can look it up online
i was a buddy hannah shop and i filmed
it so i
have experience first of all what i've
been wanting yeah we want to eat it
oh my god it's softer than i thought it
would be
fun it is so good this is the thing that
you roll
oh my gosh this is marshmallow mm-hmm i
don't think marshmallow
cream this is actually so good i'm not
baking [ __ ] i'm just eating this
is this the first time you're eating
sugar in like a year what we're doing
today
is we're having a bake off to try to
make a cake that looks like the picture
we've chosen
i feel like you chose an easy one out we
could chose whatever we wanted
you had a torah as an option because i
thought it would be funny to actually
challenge myself
this is challenging myself i am not
creative dude i have a yorkie where each
individual hair yeah good luck with that
mine's just a little bag maybe i could
just use this this is gonna be
impossible to do
yeah and they'll i mean i guess there'll
be a vote
and the loser will donate to you're
gonna be donating to
for some reason you said the synagogue
and brentwood which is probably the
place
most unneeding of money i can imagine um
can you donate to synagogues maybe i
should do to the catholic church across
the way saint martin tours just hand it
to the rabbi i'd be like here you go
anybody
he just pockets it cool i'm donating to
local food bank food bank in l.a people
are going hungry
because we're wasting all these people
are just people are going hungry
you want to go and donate it yeah we
could do that here you go you want this
mutant freak dog i made it's like i love
it
all right one of you guys can film
yourself trying to donate one of these
cakes to a random person on the street
and see how they react
let's get started we have 30 minutes to
try to get as close as possible to the
to the chosen cake okay do you know
anything about baking
um no actually i don't yeah i mean i
couldn't even bake this cake like this i
don't know how they did it like
i tried and mine go flat so this is
impressive i seriously just want to go
fat and just be like let's you know [ __ ]
let's just eat cake so i guess let's
start the clock
all right 30 minutes on the clock let's
go
oh my god oh my god that's so
nerve-wracking
okay uh-oh uh-oh
did you just fall apart yeah oh my gosh
completely okay well we can make
geez i this know how you do this okay oh
my god i'm ready
buttercream frosting wow
i'm trying to form it squeeze the cake
into a
pause you know i'm not sure if that's
the right
way and where's the brown
you're gonna mix them yeah this is the
color wheel
okay we've got okay google oh you guys
sure you guys unplugged my [ __ ] fairy
oh my god this is amazing
a little breakfast what do you blame
getting fat on if you can't bake
like how did you get fat if you don't
cook how do i get fat if i don't cook
i'm gonna
i'm gonna eat you post mate or what like
a monster yeah postmates but was it a
gradual fat or did you like
yeah it was gradual no i feel like you
kind of there was like a turning point
because you were like super skinny when
you started a h3 podcast
me i was always bad my whole life like i
gradually got fatter yours was like
no i was skinny i mean i was 1 30 when i
went to college
that's what i'm saying it wasn't a
gradual piece of medication right or
depression or both yeah deluxe
i think lexapro major fat i think the
electro pro doesn't help
i wish i had an issue like that that
made me fat like birth control or
something how the [ __ ] am i supposed to
apply this
it's just disintegrating the cake oh my
goodness i'm gonna win
but this because you literally don't
have to do anything what are you talking
about
i'm trying to make a dog oh my god
you're gonna have to donate to the
synagogue
you want me to give a bunch of rich jews
in print with a thousand dollars
yeah okay people are gonna be happy
about it
they have to convert people can we do
that for an episode what
can we have as an episode where we go to
judaism classes for converting
i don't think that's like kosher yeah
you just find one of those rabbis on
tick-tock they'll do it
okay google what colors make brown
no [ __ ] okay logo what color is mixed
to make brown
okay [ __ ] okay google you're cheating
what colors do i mix to make brown i'm
starting over i'm just gonna start over
because this is not happening
let's get those [ __ ] little leggies
out there boy oh you're like starting
leggings are you not doing the little
cushion for your dog what do you
oh the cushion [ __ ] the cushion nobody's
got time for that [ __ ] oh my god
look that doesn't even go get the little
leggies
there we go now we're talking what the
[ __ ] are you doing
i'm making hermes i'm like actually
trying unlike you
if i had a what i'm proud of myself i
never i'm this artistic what's up
aren't you like an actual designer for
like clothing like what the hell how
come we can't do this
no i don't think anyone gives me that
much credit you know a fun fact whenever
i'm doing tick tocks and i want to make
something look aesthetic
i cut and have moses do all the work and
then i act like i did it
like making the two oh this is actually
a good artist he's so good at making
everything
pretty and then i just pretend like i
did it oh that's a great strategy yeah
oh i ruined the air mess no
oh god oh no i was doing so good
actually i was like so proud of myself
okay i gotta make brown okay we got
black
i'll just i'm making a black dog
interesting
give me some red i don't know what the
[ __ ] do i know
ela you can't ask how do i make brown
mix all the colors no there's so many of
them
you can't mix all of them and i won't
have any get a look at this okay
so what do i add more of what do i add
more of
we could have at least cooked something
maybe like pasta like we could make
butter butter noodles
that would have been accomplished you
just what do you mean
butter noodles you just cook noodles in
the morning no last time you made them
whenever you left you're making them for
theater so i went home and made some and
mine smelled so much better
it smells so good
my butter noodles are amazing whatever
what's your so what's your recipe boiled
i can't tell you
because you don't make yours with pasta
water salt or trader joe's butter and i
have the secret butter
yeah i'm sure trader joe's makes the
most delicate butter oh like your
orlando lakes one from ralph's would be
any better
well i'm not claiming to have like this
exclusive butter i am
okay well it's from trader joe's so it's
not
this counter isn't even clean probably
oh
oh thank you and you have like maids
every day you have a clean house
okay don't act relatable it's probably
not even clean
i'm not trying to act relatable but like
i don't want to eat off a counter that
wasn't like wiped down in a day or two
no actually i don't care i just ate
something on the floor oh that looks
just like a bag
i'm so impressed this is the dumbest
thing ever
we are both that looks so much like a
bag i'm just super
first
i got a shape going so you can kind of
see a dog shape here
for me so how was your weekend you know
while we're here
we were packing so nothing that exciting
oh good that is exciting that's really
exciting no
you know what i do nevermind it's gonna
make me look bad say it
now i really wanna hear it um i just
lock myself in a closet and pretend i'm
busy
and then moses does all the packing for
me
i think he knows why don't you guys just
get uh packers we are tomorrow but you
know like my valuables and stuff
i'm lucky because ila is just loves
packing i think elon moses have a lot in
common
they just do [ __ ] they get [ __ ] done
it's like they're related
almost yeah it's almost like related
here we go
it's doggy time ew
yeah you know what i'm talking about i
know you put it on your instagram you're
like time to have sex this weekend i'm
like oh nobody needs to know that
my instagram yeah he said teddy was away
for the weekend and you guys were oh
no it didn't it was just a joke was it a
joke it wasn't a
i mean it wasn't a joke exactly it was a
picture of
that you were having sex someone filling
cream into uh
that was disgusting here you could can
you show that on
screen um whoever was editing yeah it
was just someone feeling creamed jelly
donuts but it wasn't a joke
just speaking you just wanted people to
know you had sex you're like i forgot
i'm having sex yesterday you could
announce it every time i bet you do
and i was like why is he announcing this
this is the best the funfetti
oh my god i feel like you just do fun of
me so you can eat
and you can't yell at you we should get
dominoes
to you know because sponsor do why are
they not sponsored by domino's gallery
they don't even want to follow me or
acknowledge me i think they would rather
me not be associated with that
like they're like this [ __ ] is giving
us free promo no i think they don't want
it because they never acknowledge me
we need to keep giving them like weird
ass promotions where they're like we'll
eventually pay us to just stop talking
about them
they're like listen just stop talking
about is there white die or what
that definitely happened it was rumored
that
louis vuitton sent snooki good gucci
purses so she would wear gucci on the
beach and not louis vuitton so it would
make
their brand look trashy and i know i
think that's true i think she like
confirmed it
who would pay me to stop doing their
[ __ ] teddy fresh
he was like listen i'm trying to build a
brand here
okay i need black i'm done that's
disgusting
shame on you at least mine looks like
what i'm supposed to make it
you're threatened you know you know
you're falling behind oh my god
i'm done with mine mine looks like my
purse and i did a little logo i did
another logo we did bram
you better show the back of that first
by the way no no
the cake is presented in the back nope
look at the back
no the back of your kitchen oh my god
it's all good you don't hide the
background cake
that's like saying oh turn around let me
see your ass maybe i don't consent to
that so i'm not consenting to my cake to
that either can we do like a dancing
with the stars episode two and see who's
the better dancer
like get a professional dancer and dance
yes who's your dream guest people always
say you say yes to my dream guess who's
your dream guest
why would i ever need a guest when i
have trisha paytas with me oh
there's no one i mean that's kind of
true i am the best guest hr has ever had
i'm playing a win i don't know if you
noticed but you're actually just sitting
back eating cake and [ __ ]
because i'm done oh my gosh
stop [ __ ] i don't swallow my food ever
how much time i got ian
oh my god dude you are so scared right
now you're scared
you're just sitting there doing nothing
i'm done i've been done oh my god i'm
not like a little
little what [ __ ] a little someone who
cares about the challenge
i won already i i frosted i did it i did
everything right
oh my god it's like cake boss okay
ew done
i gotta say i think i pulled it together
kind of
at least there's like features and a and
a formation
if to show you've got the ears the eyes
the nose the mouth you got the tail
you know what i mean the eyes are oh you
kind of killed it on the face hold on
look at this
you know you got the paws behind wow
oh so i did my air maze broken
but i ate where is it there's the handle
but i made it a frenemies broken but
where's the purse
right here there's the handle the purse
is right here and then the logo goes on
top of the
handle right here this is the purse in
the background and then this is the
label on top of the purse there's the
arames
blanket i don't i don't see the handle
it's literally right here what do you
think this brown thing is oh this just
but okay okay hilo come here
you know i made um yorkie
the parrot's biased the enemies
and it says hermes on the blanket
what's the bag it's the bergen exactly
where the handle is not even a dog that
is just
what are the handles what are the
where's your question where's the
cushion for your dog she's got a cute
little butt
no oh my god no we're voting all around
the room
okay ela go ahead and vote we don't we
don't have all day here look at did you
see the back of her cave no
backs and we don't show them back now
tell the truth
we move on yeah exactly not a cute butt
no it's stupid
i'm sorry i'm biased moses whose is
better
thank you see give us a real vote you
know what's the problem if he votes
against you you'll actually cause a
fight oh my god
dan uh would you have more consideration
for the branding of the show i'm gonna
have to go with dirk
thank you oh my gosh
dan you say more branding consideration
since when was that
a category it's bonus points which
looks more like in the image that's the
one and only question
vote you can't just say actually that's
i was going to give the same answer as
dan for the same thank you
[Laughter]
moses you didn't even [ __ ] vote you
like basically
groveling to her yeah i did i
i like the dog but it's scary i love the
dog the dog is dirty
it's not even a dog it looks like a
gargoyle okay
the ears are kind of cute but i still
ian you make the vote and be and just be
fair
you have one so it doesn't matter right
i won moses doesn't count
he's literally afraid of trisha yeah
that's your dog
of course she's gonna go for the dog
just tell me i want to know i want to
know i want to know
ian which one you like better uh
i mean trisha got the orange thank you
thank you
he's not done i'll give it to the dog
he's saying that to be nice because
you're yelling everybody mine has a nice
color
it looks more like the picture so that
you don't have your questions it doesn't
matter if you don't
just turn it the comments around tell us
who freaking won because everybody's
gonna say clearly trish has won so now
let's turn it around and do it from the
back
that's not the competition where's the
brown where's the cushion
yours looks like a little gargoyle like
you guys are it's your baby of course
you guys are going to vote for that
anyone want to re-vote i think and if i
feel like the comments should vote too
because i know i'm going to win okay i
guess i'm
so i'm donating a thousand dollars to a
brentwood
synagogue she wants me to in brentwood
[Laughter]
you know what it actually looks better
now that i pounded it
it's more squishy isn't it cuter now
yeah
congratulations brentwood synagogue what
a [ __ ] nightmare
oh my god all right guys uh
hope you all enjoyed uh this this was
kind of a train wreck i felt like but
maybe it's entertaining
all right right
i think i was robbed and i'm horrified
and disgusted
by the fact that my so-called fans and
supporters and
darius employees more like a bunch of
judases i feel like i'm jesus
and all these judas is selling me out
for a coin new testament reference from
a jew that's interesting
so that race is probably i say
problematic stuff whatever who cares
everyone's mine
well the jews believe in the new
testament they just think it's not so
magical
oh wait no no no no sorry sorry sorry
i'm backed up no they hate that [ __ ]
that shit's black
they're new testament only right
as long as you're testifying you're good
okay
i'm just confused anyways the cake
battle was amazing i love it i'm glad we
got to eat
so i have to donate now a thousand
dollars to
brentwood synagogue do you know how how
ridiculous that is
you're helping like bar mitzvahs like
you're helping like all that
i want a bar mitzvah on the show
brentwood is like the richest
neighborhood in the world
yeah true they need the money can i just
give it to a food bank
you can do that too but also the
synagogue no come on
i don't want the synagogues don't need
my money in brentwood oh with your
baller
come on it's just such a waste of money
these [ __ ]
these people are so rich and brentwood's
a synagogue and brentwood like these are
the least indeed people in the world i
literally couldn't think of
less in-need people anti-semitic it's
really not
it really is how is that anticipation
they need to also
that's where they teach they have
memberships people pay them
to go attend the temple on my behalf so
i can go to that temple
actually women aren't allowed to pray
did you know that at temple they have to
sit in the back while the men pray
it depends on the kind of all right you
were forward you had a female
i'm i'm reformed judaism is called your
reform judaism
oh [ __ ] i'm trying to get into it you
definitely are reformed trust me what
that mean
well it's like the more liberal sect of
judaism versus like conservative and
orthodox
those people won't they'll you you i
don't think you could ever even
those people won't even [ __ ] let her
in the door
yeah if i show that i've changed let's
try to make an effort to be a little
more modest
they'd be like girl walk out
but the reforms you those are the people
those are your people yeah
oh my god okay so so just to be clear
a thousand dollars to brentwood the
richest city
in the country synagogue it kind of is
right i mean brentwood
yeah hey okay okay i just want to make
just all right maybe poor people travel
to brown wood to go to the synagogue and
they can't donate
thank you vote in the comments below who
had the better cake
just so we can confirm that i am in fact
the winner and don't feel sorry for
ethan just be honest yeah i know i want
the true i
i want the truth of the truth i want to
know whose cake was better
and if i was robbed and no foot soldier
is voting
they this foot soldiers there they're
from honor they're only for your
no they're for truth and justice yours
are not the best feat on wiki feet
that's not truth and justice
how dare you that's sacrilege
how dare you whatever all right so that
was pretty fun that was wild
all right all right guys so uh see you
next week for another frenemies
and see you on
when's our next podcast stand because
we're doing it on thursday and friday
oh well i won't be here so you won't be
there so you'll have to watch without
don't watch fine wait
you want to promote something um i
no i don't have anything to promote
oh next week i will be dressing in
cosplay
because it's valentine's day it's the
week of valentine's day i will be in my
favorite romantic comedy movie cosplay
just warning i will be gender fluid that
day
so i'm just like giving you you don't
have to dress in costume not saying it's
valentine's day what is it
so i know yeah i don't want to know
because you're afraid i'll show you up
you know i'll just show you up i'm just
letting you know if you don't think
about like why it's showing up like this
like why
when do i ever think that you always
show up for like something i always
expect something and i i don't mean this
as a insult i just mean it
like you know i'm not gonna say it
because i think
i don't mean that as like an insult
because this i was going to say you
always
show up like ursula from little murphy i
love that
she's the queen not like because i just
mean that she's all done up so i was
okay
they have a live action little mermaid
and megan mccarthy supposed to play
ursula
yeah like please let me out she's not
glam oh you would be great
yeah i think because i have like porn
disney probably won't let me in the
moment oh
right right yeah you're dead but it's
funny yeah
it feels poor and full i was just saying
that you have that
you have that grandiose no but that's
not why because she's like thick
yeah yeah that's all i didn't i didn't
mean i wasn't talking about that aspect
of her personality i like that aspect of
it i like the disney games and
voluptuous i thought she was the queen i
loved her well she was like evil as [ __ ]
though
me you all right
i'm an empath see you guys
you